foreign
intensive care
it felt empty it was almost like you
were part of a movie it wasn't you that
was walking down that Corridor it just
felt very alien it felt different
I put my coat on took my bag took my
name sticker off my drawer and I was
like
it's like I'm erasing my existence
um
and then I opened the door into a very
dark night and just left
um
and it was
yeah it was it was surreal
your career in the NHS had come to an
end
[Music]
my career in the NHS was continent
Dr Ola Abbas is an experienced
consultant originally from Iraq and
she's worked in the NHS for the last 10
years but in December she resigned
that's University of Baghdad I'm not
tall enough to tilt it correctly then I
did my three years Internal Medicine
training I did my membership of the
royal colleges and I did membership of
Royal colleges in Glasgow then I did my
faculty of intensive care then I did my
acute medicine specialty certificate wow
I've never met someone with so many
qualifications I'm well decorated as a
consultant really are I mean you don't
go through all of that
wanting to resign
but if the NHS had been a good place to
work for you being the place that you
thought it would be you would still be
in it today yes
I've worked so hard to get to where I am
surely there has to be another way
around this
but I wasn't
God knows I try to figure it out there
wasn't it was just
what was available wasn't enough and I
just didn't get what I needed to keep on
giving to the system and also living my
life being happy and healthy
the NHS is facing the greatest Workforce
crisis in its 74-year history
a staffing shortage that's creating a
serious risk to patient safety
so here we are at the
hospital where you're currently working
yeah I do most of my shifts here in a e
this is Alessia Waller a junior doctor
working in the NHS which she wants out
it can be easy
to forget that you're in a world-class
tertiary Center and just feel like
you're in the trenches
there's no doubt the NHS is in a deep
crisis you see it firsthand
you are not willing to put yourself
through that
crisis any longer yeah that's yeah that
pretty much sums it up
[Applause]
my journal and this is the 19th of June
the lady with cavitating long lesion was
still going yesterday gasping with her
head thrown back and mouth the gape she
was alone in a side room drowning in air
she is dying and I'm the only one to
witness it
now
I wish I could just give myself a hug
in her first nine months of working in a
hospital Alessia says she was burnt out
signed off for a month burnout to me
feels like not knowing why you're doing
what you're doing anymore and not loving
it and actually resenting the people
that you're coming face to face with
every day I just hated going to work
I hated
um being at work I didn't feel like I
was doing my job well anymore
I was just disconnected and
disillusioned with
everything what does it tell us about
the system the NHS that you needed to
step out
I think it shows that the system is not
fit for purpose and that
um
it is past Breaking Point uh to the
point where the people that work within
it are now at Breaking Point
the NHS and everyone who works in the
NHS knows this and says this it's like
the worst kept secret
you just feel like a cog and a machine
but the machine is falling apart
in their first two years of training
Junior doctors go from placement to
placement every four months new ID
passes new logins new people new
departments that's Complicated by the
fact that the NHS is still using these
old Windows computers that take about 10
minutes to turn on and log in you know
you may not get your logins for the
first two weeks that you turn up on the
ward around the consultant's annoyed
because he's like why haven't you got
the patient's blood results up you're
like well I haven't got login for the
blood results system we're made to feel
that we kind of we're not worth the kind
of the space the security the I.T the
the correct pay on the correct day and
it is so demoralizing and it makes
doctors feel so undervalued and I think
that contributes to burnout because
you're like why am I breaking my back
when I can't even do the basics
[Music]
the department for Health and Social
care says there are record numbers of
doctors working in the NHS but that
doesn't tell the full story a record
number are resigning too
3229 doctors resigned from the NHS in
England last year the number who left
because they wanted a better work-life
balance has doubled over the past decade
to 341 last year and the number of
doctors leaving has accelerated rapidly
since the pandemic last year almost 13
000 doctors in the UK gave up their
license that's up by nine percent on the
year before
the NHS is a Crossroads with the right
investment with the right commitment
actually it has a very bright future
because the staff are desperate to make
this work but we need to
retain recruit and we need to stop
the driving away of the workforce
they're feeling undervalued and what
they've seen is a sequence of below
inflation pay Rises so they've seen
their pay in relative terms Fall by
about 26 percent since 2008. you know
they're not worth a quarter less than
they were in 2008
I can tell you what it feels like to be
on the receiving end of a government
that appears not to be funding the NHS
well so what does that tell us then in
your view about the government's
attitude towards the current NHS
pressures that we're facing this
government refuses
to acknowledge that there is a crisis in
the NHS and by only offering sticking
plasters to fix it the situation will
only get worse
one solution to solving the staff
shortage is to train more doctors but
that is easier said than done
the government caps medical student
places in England seven and a half
thousand students got a place this year
labor says it would double that if it
came to power taxing High earners to pay
for it
okay come on in guys
all right we're going to be working with
Sim man today Kate Lilly and John our
second year medical students here at
Newcastle University today they're
learning clinical skills which they'll
be expected to put into practice once
they enter the NHS Kate so your next
patient Stephen has just come into have
his Bloods taken uh are you all right
doing that yeah that's right I want to
find out how these doctors of Tomorrow
feel about the NHS of today it's almost
quite exciting because that was the end
goal that was what you'd always wanted
to be
um it will be scary but I'm it would be
scary regardless of what's going on at
the minute but I think for medical
students at least it's important to
focus on what we've got in front of us
right now
thank you
of course it worries me I mean you read
books you read articles you can't avoid
it are you nervous about your journey
through this
of course I'm nervous but I'm more
excited than nervous
talk to your medical student self now
about embarking on medicine
what would you be saying to them
don't do it if it's your calling
go for it nobody's going to be able to
talk you out of it and I'm not here to
talk anyone out of it
but know what you're getting into
Ola a consultant in both critical care
and acute medicine kovid was the last
straw
it was so traumatizing having to see
what we saw
during that pandemic and for people to
think that we can come out and carry on
as it was
it was just unbelievable
[Music]
NHS England data shows a gaping hole in
Dr rotors the NHS currently has 9 000
vacancies that remain unfilled
Alessia now looks likely to add to that
she's planning to move to the United
States to pursue her dream of becoming a
surgeon the NHS can no longer offer me
the training that I need or want
I don't feel valued I don't feel
supported and
I think I might have a better chance
somewhere else doctors are looking
around at the environment that we're
working in and going this is no longer
worth it we have been sold a lot of
books for a long time
Junior doctors have now voted in favor
of strike action which means they'll
join nurses and ambulance staff in a
walkout which will place intense
pressure on the NHS
they are not doing this because they
want to they are doing this because
they are not being listened to
the department for Health and Social
care told us that supporting and
retaining NHS staff is a key priority
and 6.6 billion pounds of extra money is
being spent in the next two years they
say vacancies are increasing because
services are expanding to tackle waiting
lists post covid we are short staffed
across all disciplines before us all
specialties
and it is alarming when you have someone
who's been so dedicated for the job for
so long
but being forced to leave because they
just can't stay in that job anymore it's
a massive system failure